mother closing an entree Oh deep three
CJ positions himself perfectly to the
board Semien into the lane muscles to
the glass and laid it in and fight
through the contact from Herter things
up the floor chops to step surveys
cross-court pass intercept the tray on
up the poor he'll take a look go to the
revs earners three
Bazemore head to CJ he's got a step on
the big man herder closing fast dame
trailing for three damian lillard
cranks it in and transition the Blazers
off to the seven-point lead is a starter
and the guy who couldn't come reliably
off the bench they're planning for five
years chasing young off the screen who
drops the lower just as they have in the
past with other guys did you know CJ sit
sit remember economy fouled will head to
the line
James is put on nails they performance
start to finish
tre young sweeps it right to left
hesitates with that left hand and it
sends it a floater hallelujah good to
see it go through the rim inside though
Parker Lance deep and score penetrate
and pitch it's there look for it
Blazers with seven assists on 12 field
goals made murder outside way outside
for three
the Bari Parkers claims this rebound
Trey young catch and shoot
and then make moves with the dribble
Trey Young has already shown you what
makes him tick
no justice boy yeah yes built to spring
plays one way hard Trey young getting
into that little in-between gear to lay
it up in it and then the second of the
back-to-back against the defending world
champions Ryan arrest young the other
way trying to shake free high runner off
this is good because there's a 5 of 16
beyond the earth Trey young off the
screen the 1 - hands off - hunter in the
corner standstill triples good game sees
to those right a limb and laid it in
with a left hand get this step and then
it's him kind of one-on-one with that
big man he's winning that battle loaded
it right over to top bonus lasers to
lead it to right side rolling to the
level of the ball gives a little jump
down he's got 13 for the night Mario
likes to facilitate out here
goodbye young that's young off he still
maintains the dribble but draws a foul
it's outside the paint a pass
hard-to-handle Mario let it get away
back come Parker and he walked through
the basketball that's the one
we're tied at 52 for minutes got buying
third quarter Dave way outside yeah
[Applause]
babies pops back greens tons of
something
we need to partner to strange because
the opposite direction in the heated for
Jabari straight away look man they
chan - jab who runs it right
he's knocked down marker comes the other
way on the foot ends d'être on back to
Parker at the rim to lay it up a tenth
good two-man play on the run
[Applause]
[Music]
pick and roll with Jones to the two-hand
Jam in the Blazers called time to make
some observations and a few adjustments
[Music]
TRAI off that screen again gets in deep
as we've licked it with the underhand
motion to the fourth level to that maybe
in range up there
the logo putter a deep one got it free
but he's in a couple tonight had only
six threes made on the season coming
into this was his time cap it's his time
of eight he's at two three
chasing young going under the screen
catches young on the exchange from Jose
same thing looking like that fourth
quarter at the Clippers young trying to
answer does
but that free there gives Atlanta Lita
two eight lead changes in his ballgame
outside Damien had three up as many as
eight Atlanta's largest lead has been
five days per there he goes it up an
issue for Trey young and he comes floats
it up on it and Atlanta takes a lead a
three Dame into the lanes works his way
in on Joe sheer force of will which you
nowise afternoon Festiva second leading
scorer not 28 Blazers were then one Trey
young we downtown ten to shoot
living outside with eight to shoot long
way from home with six ready go rides
inside steps into the lane cuts on a
window and laid it in sees two and now
hunter will step up on side rescreened
they bought the bit fires the base for
another three add another one
ten days worn back in and rock from
three-point range
he has to get to Portland he's got to
get to Portland
was over two from three on Friday night
the end of the lane comes Jones for the
hammer
Bazemore takes it off the window damn
spot
[Music]
hey Sonia
they have broken this baby open here and
over - Alki 32 seconds left Young has it
stripped bike gave me a little give me
that off to Florida Whiteside what's up
you guys this Taylor Brooks with
bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content